going to the movies is fun but actually
making those movies can be stressful
difficult and even dangerous at times in
fact have never been a number of stars
who nearly died during the filming of
some of your favorite movies here's a
look at some iconic movie scenes that
nearly killed actors Kevin Costner you
could safely say it has never been a
better movie about post-apocalyptic boat
fights than water world but this
supremely guilty pleasure didn't just
kill Kevin Costner status of an a-list
star it's also nearly killed him period
while he was filming a scene that had
him tethered to the top of the sailboats
mast a sudden storm swept over the set
and course Costner dangling from the
rickety mast wind and waves smashed into
him repeatedly
but the squall made it too dangerous for
the crew to pull him down according to
people Costner later told a friend that
it almost died during a 30-minute ordeal
luckily he had his own way of dealing
with the water
Geils okay Jamie Alexander superhero
movies come with big action and even
bigger safety precautions and yet
accidents can still happen as actress
Jamie Alexander who plays SIF
unfortunately found out on the set of
Thor the dark world while she didn't
reveal the scene in which the accident
happened Alexander did tell MTV that she
majorly damaged her back in the accident
I herniated a disc in my thoracic spine
dislocated my left shoulder
tore my right rhomboid and chipped 11
vertebra the next morning I got in a car
to go to the hospital and they sat in
the car and compressed my spine a little
bit
and the ones paralyzed in my right leg
and my right hand so I was in the
hospital for a week Kate Winslet
considering her character rose as one of
the few people who survives the sinking
of the Titanic
it would have been grimly ironic if Kate
Winslet hadn't even survived filming the
1997 blockbuster classic but during the
scene where Winslet and Leonardo
DiCaprio flee the flooded lower decks
Winslet was dragged underwater and was
unable to come up for air after her
Coast Guard caught on a metal gate
Winslet was traumatized by the
near-death experience
but director James Cameron D let's I
catch your breath and then set up for
another take
since Winslet had just a room in that
one with a silly near-death experience
Jim Caviezel Mel Gibson's 2004 epic The
Passion of the Christ electrified
audiences energizing the faithful and
telling the film into one of the most
unlikely hit films in Hollywood history
but things were even more electrified on
set as the man who played Jesus himself
Jim Caviezel was struck by an
honest-to-god lightning bolt while
filming the Sermon on the Mount he told
the 700 club I was lit up like a
Christmas tree what the extra saw was
fire coming out of the right and the
left side of my head illumination around
the whole body was that the wrath of God
or was Caviezel simply standing on a
hill during a lightning storm who can
say
Martin Sheen they say war is health but
war never visited the set of Apocalypse
Now
the infamously troubled production drove
plenty of people including director
Francis Ford Coppola and star Marlon
Brando to the brink of insanity
ditalion they told me
they're gone totally insane but the one
events I've came the closest to grinding
the production to a standstill
was 36 year old Martin Sheen's heart
attack in the middle of the jungle
according to the Daily Mail the crew
found the film's lead actor crawling
along the road looking for help as
Coppola relates it that incident was
nearly the final straw that sent him
into a nervous breakdown
he told Rolling Stone Marty's heart
attack severely traumatized my nervous
system we didn't know if he was going to
make it if Coppola thinks his nervous
system was traumatized imagine how she
must have felt after you know actually
suffering the heart attack thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your loved team
[Music]